Batman has always been an inspiration to
gym goers and anyone looking to improve
himself because he represents the
pinnacle of what we imagined to be
possible in terms of human performance
he is peak human and he got here through
grit and determination alone if that's
what Batman represents then Steve Rogers
represents the next step
he is just beyond peak human he is the
soldier of tomorrow
his speed strength and stamina are
greater than we can ever imagine
achieving but it's only really a bit of
transhumanism that stands between him
and us you're a laboratory experiment
Rogers everything special about using my
bottle what makes him so interesting is
that the concept isn't really that
far-fetched in fact this is something
that DARPA and other organizations have
been working on for a while creating
soldiers that are stronger faster
smarter and better than even the best
human athletes and it's not that far
removed from what many of us are trying
to accomplish with pre-workouts
nootropics protein shakes and in some
cases anabolic steroids of course and
there are even some more out there bio
mods already available to us regular
folks too some of which began a life has
died after experiments so what can we
learn from the performance-enhancing
strategies used by military scientists
how long until wars are fought by
superhumans in this article I'll be
examining the possibility of creating
real-life super soldiers the DARPA
program that was concerned at the
development of super soldiers was
actually referred to as the
metabolically dominant soldier or later
peak soldier performance these both
sound even more awesome than super
soldier a lot of this research revolves
around the subject of powered
exoskeletons and other types of
equipment including fabrics with into
woven nano muscle fibers jump belts and
the said demand project looking at
deco-inspired gloves for wall-crawling
like spider-man
I'll come back to that in future but for
now we're interested in human
enhancements the project was actually
launched in 2002 with the aim of
reducing the susceptibility of troops to
stress sleep deprivation fatigue pain
and blood loss whilst also enhancing
strength speed endurance memory and
learning DARPA has been known to
investigate the use of nootropics like
aniracetam and modafinil as well among
many other things the project looked
into a nasal spray called a wreck
in a aka hypo [ __ ] to help reduce the
need for sleep this is a nasal spray
intended to reduce the need for sleep by
essentially hacking the sleep/wake cycle
this was work similarly to modafinil and
it's something I intend to look into
further in future it also has shown to
boost cognitive performance as yet there
are no known side effects but it hasn't
been studied in the long term and it's
not yet widely available I wouldn't
recommend buying this from any dodgy
online site but it is an interesting
area of research
likewise dart also has a history of
experimentation with transcranial direct
current stimulation for enhanced
learning and activating flow States this
means essentially running a low-level
current through the brain not enough to
force the neurons to fire but just
enough to increase their excitability
make them more likely to fire the
studies here are very interesting it's
something I'll be coming back to in
future although there are articles over
at the bi-linear comm you can read right
now in terms of endurance another
interesting project was the use of
cooling gloves intended to regulate
temperature and prevent fatigue from
overheating I'll be looking in depth at
thermal regulation soon but it just goes
to show that well temperature management
plays a much bigger role in endurance
than we often give it credit for they've
also looked at drugs for enhancing
endurance and that's sometimes referred
to as energizer bunny in fatigues a Dan
Farber Cancer Institute pathologist
lambo chen likewise found that blending
a green tea extract with B vitamins
could triple the endurance of lab rats
by exponentially increasing their
mitochondria production unfortunately
the same drink only managed to increase
the performance of cyclists by 3% in
human trials but that said the drink is
still being tested paying vaccines are
another area of interest for DARPA
another very interesting project looked
at creating pain vaccines to block the
sense of pain in less than 10 seconds
lasting for up to 30 days what's more
that this pain blocking would not
prevent the initial shock and reflex
response necessary to avoid injury so
you'd still pull your hand away from a
hot stove for instance this easy target
chronic pain more specifically by
working on the inflammatory response
this research is currently undergoing
animal trials in 2008 Ducker officially
abandoned its metabolic dominance
program that doesn't mean they aren't
still interested in creating super
soldiers in 2009 one researcher Andrew
her was tasked with researching
something called unit cohesion this is
the ability of a group of soldiers to
continue fighting even when exhausted
dehydrated confused and stressed
munication is often one of the deciding
factors in the outcome of a severe
conflict and it could be considered very
akin to a kind of group flow state which
is something that people like Steven
Kotler have observed hair identified
many of the newer chemicals that would
enhance or dampen performance during
such a high-stress situation and use
things such as transcranial direct
current stimulation and the injections
of neuropeptide Y in order to try and
keep soldiers alert and calmly focused I
discussed neuropeptide Y in my video on
flow States recently along with DHEA it
appears to be one of the chemicals that
helps us support optimal performance in
high stakes scenarios I was interested
in using neuropeptide Y as part of a
nootropic spec myself though I need to
look into this a lot deeper as it also
causes a raise in blood pressure along
with increased appetite and weight gain
not so Captain America the British Royal
Society also shed light on for
small-scale DARPA bio mod programs
focused on neurological enhancement and
stress reduction brain machine interface
programs are also very much on the table
so DARPA has researched and still is
researching a whole host of fascinating
super soldier like techniques and
strategies and we can learn just by
looking at which things they've chosen
to focus on and then doing our own
research into those areas what really
makes the idea of Captain America so
appealing to many people though is the
fact that he gets all of his powers and
abilities from a single serum the idea
that you could inject something once or
even occasionally and thus gain a
permanent increase in muscle is
something that many people find
inherently appealing so this possible
actually this is also something that
researchers have been working on I've
previously discussed the idea of using
gene doping for instance to block the
production of myostatin Mya Sutton is
naturally occurring substance that
limits the amount of muscle that the
human body will pack on presumably to
keep us energy efficient
gene doping techniques allow us to
temporarily or even permanently block
this substance resulting in an increase
in muscle mass of
to 30% the technique has been used
successfully and repeatedly in animal
studies and the mutation has even been
named to occur naturally in humans and
as I reported recently won by hacker
streamed the video injecting himself was
CRISPR - just such an end
CRISPR being the delivery method that is
used to insert these new genes this
technology is far from perfected though
CRISPR is not a flawless technique is
ideal for use in controlled animal
studies to help us improve our
understanding of DNA it'll only be
effective within a small area meaning
that it might take multiple injections
to see much of a difference across the
body unless it's injected into a zygote
prior to birth not only that but it can
sometimes cut the DNA in the wrong place
resulting in strange defects or
potentially even cancer so it's a
high-risk procedure even if some people
portray it otherwise not only that but
blocking my statin entirely might be a
full servant in itself seeing as it can
lead to tendon damage but there is
another exercise pill out there which is
further along and which some people are
already taking
it's called GW five oh one five one six
but its friends call it five sixteen the
aim is to mimic the effects of endurance
exercise on the gene PPAR Delta
effectively if successful this pill
could replace the need for distance
running or endurance exercise altogether
when five one six binds to the PPAR
delta g enhances its fat-burning signal
in one mouse study two mice were
observed these mice were fed a high-fat
and sugar diet similar to cookie dough
and were left to their own devices with
a wheel in their cage now a code named
couch potato was given no five one six
and was observed to be overweight
lethargic and greasy their words not
mind
Mouse B on the other hand was given five
one six and was not only lean and toned
but also full of energy in monkeys
administration of five one six lowest
bad cholesterol insulin levels and
triglycerides tim wilson who discovered
the drug while looking for a treatment
for diabetes initially believed that
this was a wonder drug for metabolic
syndrome and yes some bodybuilders and
other athletes are already using the
substance with runners reporting that it
helps them to avoid hitting the wall
increasing endurance seemingly by
increasing the availability of ATP
in 2009 world anti-doping agency banned
five-one-six--
that's when you know you're doing
something right the catch five-one-six--
is highly toxic animal studies also
share the development of cancer in many
of the participants across numerous
organs the FDA determined that the risks
outweigh the side-effects and it was
shelved pending a 70-year study so just
to be clear I am absolutely not
recommending or advocating the use of
506 but it is interesting and given time
and study perhaps researchers could
overcome its current limitations the
molecular and developmental biologists
responsible for the aforementioned Mouse
study ron evans has speculated that the
same effect could eventually be achieved
on a more permanent basis by a gene
doping by targeting the PPAR delta gene
in time gene doping techniques as well
will inevitably improve with better
vectors delivery methods and perhaps
with more of a focus on epigenetics
rather than permanent change
likewise methods to mitigate the effects
on tendons could eventually make
myostatin blocking a safe option to if
you could then combine both into a
single injection you would have a single
serum with meet you faster stronger more
resilient and more ripped permanently
just like Steve Rogers now combine that
with cooling gloves nano muscle fiber a
pain vaccine and endurance cocktail and
nootropics cool right most of us use
chemicals and supplements to enhance our
performance in the gym and at work in
some way almost all of us use
painkillers you could say that we're all
super soldiers so there you have it
super soldiers are real and more awesome
supplements are coming along with Batman
that makes Captain America certainly one
of the most realistic superheroes what
can you take from this right now I'm not
saying that you should go out there and
experiment with any of these things in
fact it should maybe alarm you that some
of the stuff already taking in is quite
as potent as it is I use D MHA in my
crack and pre-workout right now and
while the effects are wicked I'm not
sure it's such a good idea
more on this soon in future that I'll be
researching a lot of these ideas in more
detail such as the use of a Rex in a and
increasing nu a peptide white so stay
tuned for that and my hope is to
eventually use this to create a flow
stack which I'll share in part three of
my flow state video series the bio
hackers keeping an idea what darf is
doing it's just a sensible way of
getting some in
raishin and if we're to take the lead of
darker than areas that we should all
look into a little more include things
like unit cohesion flow states
thermoregulation
mitochondrial density and accelerated
learning apparently that is how you
build a super-soldier so hope you found
this video useful interesting guys if
did then please leave a like please
share it around that helps me immensely
comment down below and let me know if
there's any interesting studies or
research that you know of that I've
missed and be sure to stay tuned to
subscribe to the channel if you want
more on brain training transhumanism
bodybuilding fitness calisthenics
productivity technology all that good
stuff you name it if that sounds good
then thanks a ton for watching and I'll
see you next time bye for now
um guys remember I'm still collecting
images and videos and descriptions of
home Batcave so that's any cool home gym
slash Home Office I'm gonna be doing a
video on my home Batcave the bio lab and
I'd love to feature some of the
contributions that you our guys have so
that we can compare notes and see what
makes an awesome space for productivity
and fitness training so if you've got a
home gym or home office then head over
to the Facebook page at facebook.com
slash the Pioneer and find that thread
and then submit your picture or video
and I might feature it in that upcoming
video so yeah check it out thanks a ton
oh and of course as always check out the
accompanying article to go to this video
over at the bio near comm there's a much
more detailed version and you'll find
extra information on old fashioned
methods I used to enhance the
performance of soldiers among other
things they checked out oh and all the
studies of course